[Music]
foreign
if we had but
I can't Faith how about faith
faith faith
isn't it they changed it most of them
man here at Rotten Tomatoes we believe
that there's only one thing better than
watching a movie and that's watching a
movie about a movie ever since Hollywood
started rolling film on the big screens
the subjects of the people and Minds
behind the camera has been one of
popular entries these stories gave
audiences a more than intimate look at
the business of filmmaking and the drama
that unfolds before the drama begins
still wonderful isn't it
and no dialogue
we didn't need dialogue we had faces
there just aren't any faces like that
anymore in order to make our list these
titles had to be based around the film
industry which includes Bonafide
depictions as well as a little bit of
satire so get ready to get meta as we
count down our list of the best movies
about movies
[Music]
yeah
number 10 Once Upon a Time in Hollywood
actor Rick Dalton gained Fame and
Fortune by starring in a 1950s
television Western but is now struggling
to find meaningful work and a Hollywood
that he doesn't recognize anymore he
spends most of his time drinking and
paling around with Cliff Booth his easy
going best friend and long time stunt
double Rick also happens to live next
door to Roman Polanski and Sharon Tate
the filmmaker and budding actress whose
Futures will forever be altered by
members of the Manson family starring
Leonardo DiCaprio Brad Pitt Margot
Robbie and directed by Quentin Tarantino
critics say thrillingly unrestrained yet
solidly crafted Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood tempers Tarantino's
provocative impulses with the clarity of
a mature filmmaker's vision
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
not bad Cato
try that again
probably
oh
come on
number nine hail Caesar
in the early 1950s Eddie Mannix is busy
at work trying to solve all the problems
of the actors and filmmakers at Capital
pictures his latest assignments involve
a disgruntled director a singing Cowboy
a beautiful swimmer and a handsome
dancer as if all this wasn't enough
Mannix faces his biggest challenge when
Baird Whitlock gets kidnapped while in
costume for the swords and sandals epic
hail Caesar if the studio doesn't pay a
hundred thousand dollars it's the end of
the line for the movie star starring
Josh Brolin George Clooney Alden iron
Reich and directed by Joel and Ethan
Cohen critics say packed with period
detail and perfectly cast hail Caesar
finds a Coen Brothers delivering an
agreeably lightweight Love Letter to
post-war Hollywood
foreign
let's try this your line just said as I
said say your line exactly as I'm about
to just as I'm about to do sure okay
so simple
[Music]
would that it was a say well would the
detour so simple would that it was the
same idea why do you say that why'd you
say twerk well you should say like I
said yes it would that it twice
a sample
just watch my mouth with the Detroit
system keep your head still with it
I'm trying to say that Mr Lawrence
Lawrence
I thought
a minute ago it was Lorraine no we can
use Christian there's my good day but
Lawrence is fine just as I call you
Herby Okay so
simple
trippingly would the deters a simple
tripping like you don't say tripping we
say the line tripping wood that it was
number eight adaptation
Nicholas Cage is Charlie Kaufman a
confused La screenwriter overwhelmed by
feelings of inadequacy sexual
frustration self-loathing and by the
screenwriting Ambitions of his
freeloading twin brother Donald while
struggling to adapt the Orchid Thief by
Susan Orlean Kaufman's life spins from
pathetic to bizarre the lives of Kaufman
Orleans book become strangely
intertwined as each one search for
passion collides with the others
starring in Nicolas Cage Meryl Streep
Chris Cooper and directed by Spike Jones
critics say dizzingly original the loopy
multi-layered adaptation is both funny
and thought-provoking
yes
sir what if a writer is attempting to
create a story where nothing much
happens
where people don't change they don't
have any epiphanies they struggle and
are frustrated and nothing is resolved
more reflection of the real world
the real world
yes sir
first of all you write a screenplay
without conflict of Crisis you'll bore
your audience to tears
secondly
nothing happens in the world
are you out of your [__] mind
people are murdered every day
there's
genocide War corruption every [__]
day somewhere in the world somebody
sacrifices his life to save somebody
else every [__] day someone somewhere
takes a conscious decision to destroy
someone else
people find love people lose it for
Christ's sake a child watches a mother
beaten to death on the steps of a church
someone goes hungry somebody else
betrays his best friend for a woman
if you can't find that stuff in life
then you my friend don't know crap about
life and why the [__] are you wasting my
two precious hours with your movie
I don't have any use for it I don't have
any bloody use for it
number seven Ed Wood
because of his eccentric habits and
baffling strange films director Edward
is a Hollywood Outcast nevertheless with
the help of the formerly famous Bella
Lugosi and a devoted cast and crew of
Show Business Misfits who believe in
Ed's off-kilter Vision the filmmaker is
able to bring his oversized dreams to
cinematic life despite a lack of
critical or Commercial Success Ed and
his friends managed to create an oddly
endearing series of extremely low budget
films starring Johnny Depp Martin Landau
Sarah Jessica Parker and directed by Tim
Burton critics say Tim Burton and Johnny
Depp team up to feed the life and work
of cult hero Ed Wood with typically
strange and wonderful results
Road
stop b c 97 take one mark
action
be there
Beware of the Big Green Dragon that sits
on your doorstep
it's little boys
puppy dog tails B
fat snails
see there
take care
be fair
wait
a string
pull the string
cut
foreign
number six Boogie Nights
in the San Fernando Valley in 1977
teenage busboy Eddie Adams gets
discovered by porn director Jack Horner
who transforms him into adult film
sensation Dirk Diggler brought into a
supportive circle of friends including
fellow actors Amber Waves roller girl
and Reed Rothschild Dirk fulfills all
his Ambitions but a toxic combination of
drugs and egotism threatens to take him
back down starring Mark Wahlberg Burt
Reynolds Julianne Moore and directed by
Paul Thomas Anderson critics say
grounded in strong characters bold
themes and subtle storytelling Boogie
Nights is a groundbreaking film both for
director PT Anderson and star Mark
Wahlberg
I know who you are I write about you the
magazine inside Amber Amanda's right he
made those right
I was like so now you know I'm not full
of
dog
when I come back to the table and uh
I'd love to but I gotta work you have to
work good morning you know pay the rent
well yeah I mean no I I need money but I
don't pay rent I still live at home
probably already
17.
17 year old piece of gold
once you come back to the table
I do know you I know who you are I mean
I'd love to come back to your table for
a drink and obviously you're not full of
thought
but I just couldn't
I Got a Feeling by those jeans are so
wonderful just waiting to get out
number five the artist
in the 1920s actor George Valentin is a
Bonafide matinee Idol with many adoring
fans while working on his latest film
George finds himself falling in love
with an engineer named Pepe Miller and
what's more it seems Pepe feels the same
way but George is reluctant to cheat on
his wife with a beautiful young actress
the growing popularity of sound in
movies further separates the potential
lovers as George's career begins to fade
while Pepe's star Rises starring Jean du
Jardine Berenice beijio John Goodman and
directed by Michael hazenovicius critics
say a crowd-pleasing tribute to the
magic of Silent Cinema the artist is a
clever joyous film with delightful
performances and visual style to spare
foreign
[Music]
number four Sunset Boulevard
an aging silent film Queen refuses to
accept that her stardom has ended she
hires a young screenwriter to help set
up her movie comeback the screenwriter
believes he can manipulate her but he
soon finds out he is wrong his green
writer's ambivalence about their
relationship and her unwillingness to
let go leads to a situation of violence
Madness and death starring William
Holden Gloria Swanson Eric Von stroheim
and directed by Billy Wilder critics say
arguably the greatest movie about
Hollywood Billy Wilder's Masterpiece
Sunset Boulevard is a tremendously
entertaining combination of Noir black
comedy and character study
[Music]
I can't go on with the scene I'm too
happy
Mr DeMille do you mind if I say a few
words thank you
I just want to tell you all how happy I
am to be back in the studio making a
picture again
you don't know how much I've missed all
of you
and I promise you I'll never desert you
again because after Salome we'll make
another picture on another picture
see this is my life
it always will be there's nothing else
cameras
wonderful people
all right Mr DeMille I'm ready for my
close-up
[Music]
number three the player
certain that the anonymous threats he's
been receiving are the work of David
Kane producer Griffin Mill tries to fix
things over cocktails instead Griffin
ends up murdering the screenwriter and
courting the Dead Man's Girlfriend as
police investigate Griffin concentrates
on a prestigious film that might
reinvigorate his career but he soon
learns that David's demise hasn't been
forgotten by everyone in Hollywood
starring Tim Robbins Greta scotchi Fred
Ward and directed by Robert Altman
critics say bitingly cynical without
succumbing to bitterness the player is
one of the all-time great Hollywood
satires and an ensemble driven highlight
of the Altman ovra cut from the D.A to
an up Market Suburban neighborhood a
couple have a fight
he lives in a fit getting a car it's a
same Rainy Night
the car spins out on a road goes into a
ravine the body is Swept Away
now when the police examine the car
and the brakes have been tampered with
it's murder
and the D.A decides to go for the big
one
he's going to put the wife in the gas
chamber but the D.A falls in love with
the way but of course he falls in love
with the wave but he puts her in the gas
chamber anyway
then
he finds out the husband is alive
he faked his death
the D.A breaks into the prison runs down
death row
but I guess they're too late
the gas pellets have been dropped
she's dead
that's not a dry eye in my house
she's dead she's dead
she's dead because that's the reality
the innocent die
number two eight and a half
troubled Italian filmmaker Guido and
sell me struggles with creative stasis
as he attempts to get a new movie off
the ground overwhelmed by his work and
personal life the director Retreats into
his thoughts which often focus on his
loves both past and present and
frequently wander into Fantastical
territory as he tries to sort out his
many entanglements romantic and
otherwise and Sami finds his production
becoming more and more autobiographical
starring Marcelo mastroianni Claudia
Cardinal a nuke Amy and directed by
Federico Fellini critics say inventive
thought-provoking and funny eight and a
half represents the arguable peak of
Federico Fellini's many towering Feats
of Cinema
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and before we reveal number one here are
some honorable mentions
Tropic Thunder
[Music]
tugs feed men pampered action star sets
out for Southeast Asia to take part in
the biggest most expensive war movie
produced but soon after filming begins
he and his co-stars Oscar winner Kirk
Lazarus comic Jeff Portnoy and the rest
of the crew must become real soldiers
while fighting breaks out in that part
of the Jungle starring Jack Black Robert
Downey Jr Jay Baruchel and Ben Stiller
who also directed the film critics say
with biting satire plenty of subversive
humor and an unforgettable turn by
Robert Downey Jr Tropic Thunder is a
triumphant late summer comedy
oh
you were my
see that's what I think it is Damien I
think it's the line yeah I don't know if
four leaf would say that would four leaf
were you crying when your hands blew up
no you eat it yeah I mean so now we're
in rewrites right where are you going
let's rewrite it Action Jackson can't
cry that's what's going down you know
what Kirk I'm ready
what team the scene is about
emotionality where is it uh now it's
time to flip the script me until Chinese
New Year wait for my man you're tangling
me you're [__] tangling me you're
tangling me no stop tailgating me you
paste the tea bag I'm going potty
you think
here they go
an inbound planes are inbounds
that's the signal go go go go go go go
let's go freaking get here
ah
Mother Nature just pissed her pants suit
Bowfinger
on the verge of bankruptcy and desperate
for his big break aspiring filmmaker
Bobby Bowfinger concocts a crazy plan to
make his Ultimate Dream movie rallying a
ragtag team that includes a Starry Eyed
ingenue a has been Diva and a film
studio gopher he sets out to shoot a
blockbuster featuring the biggest star
in Hollywood kit Ramsey only without
letting Ramsay know he's in the picture
starring Steve Martin Eddie Murphy
Heather Graham and directed by Frank Oz
critics say a witty commentary on Modern
filmmaking with enough jokes to keep it
entertaining throughout
[Applause]
from here
are you talking about not many people
can do what you just did the stunt
drivers were really impressed weren't
they
really now guess what we got an errand
we want you to do really we want you to
go to Starbucks get coffee for everybody
a really complicated
and you're the only person who can do it
yes
okay but first let's do this one more
time
Saving Mr Banks
spurred on by a promise he made to his
daughters Walt Disney embarks on what
would become a 20-year quest to obtain
the movie rights to Mary Poppins the
author PL Travers proves to be an
uncompromising curmudgeon who has no
intention of letting her beloved
characters become mangled in the
Hollywood Machine however when the book
stops selling and she finds herself in
need of money Travers reluctantly agrees
to consider Disney's proposition
starring Emma Thompson Tom Hanks Paul
Giamatti and directed by John Lee
Hancock critics say aggressively likable
and sentimental to a fault Saving Mr
Banks pays tribute to the Disney Legacy
with excellent performances and sweet
high-spirited charm you can't imagine
how excited I am to finally meet you
Walt Mr dizzy was an old man isn't that
right now absolutely
[Music]
say hello to the one and only family
trout it's so nice to meet you
you know I I can't believe PL trap is
right here in my office all these years
almost 20 of them yes
could be a long Year I wish you could
have seen me then Pam
lean is a whip it I was a racehorse well
anyway now here you are and look at Jew
I could just eat you up
that would be appropriate
finally number one Singing in the Rain a
spoof of the turmoil that Afflicted the
movie industry in the late 1920s when
movies went from Silent to sound when
two silent movie stars Don Lockwood and
Lena Lamont latest movie is made into a
musical A Chorus girl is brought in to
Dublin is speaking and singing Don is on
top of the world until Lina finds out
starring Gene Kelly Debbie Reynolds
Donald O'Connor and directed by Stanley
Donnan and Gene Kelly critics say clever
incisive and funny singing in the rain
is a masterpiece of the classical
Hollywood Musical My Heart Belongs to
another
telly ever since I met him I can't eat
him out of my mind sounds good and Loud
huh
[Applause]
oh kid danger
ous
you never could remember where the
microphone was bought
his Cupid himself
written by his Arrow
well my friends that about does it for
us be sure to stay tuned to the Rotten
Tomatoes channel for more of the
entertainment content you love until
next time I'm your host Naz Perez and
we'll see you back here for more top
tens on the Rotten Tomatoes countdown
foreign
[Music]